what would you want to be known for what
is the position that you want to own
defending a position is easy
establishing it is hard it's one of my
favorite quotes about business and he
said the secret to business is staying
in business we want to start new
channels we want to start new podcasts
we want to write new books we've got 42
different course ideas most successful
companies find a winning formula and
then they stick with that winning
formula one of our goals at think media
is to help you think different than
everybody else so that you can create an
unfair advantage over the competition
and I'm excited for this episode of the
think media podcast where we're going to
be going through six questions that when
you think deeply about these and you
answer them for yourself for your
channel for your business they will lead
to your success on YouTube this year
these six questions are actually coming
from a book called positioning the
battle for your mind and it's one of the
classic books on market marketing that
is very powerful now we've touched on
this in the podcast in the past and
we'll link up some of the previous
episodes for you to check out but these
are six questions that the authors give
us that are simple to ask but difficult
to answer so I want to encourage you to
buckle your seat Bel for this episode of
the think media podcast because I think
it'll be maybe one of the most
challenging interesting and at first it
may be hard to think about how these
even apply to your situation but if you
will be diligent and if you will lean in
to this episode I believe that these
questions can lead you to Clarity that
will help you increase your views get
more subscribers and ultimately
experience more success on YouTube
Here's question number one what position
do you own now what positioning is
here's the author's definition It's
thinking in Reverse instead of starting
with yourself you want to start with the
mind of the prospect start with the mind
of the target audience here's why this
one is hard if you're just starting the
position you own in the prospect's mind
is nothing right like you you don't
you're not known yet but one of the
things this book talks about is it talks
about like what is Coca-Cola's
positioning what is Pepsi's positioning
what is Volkswagen's positioning when
you think of Volkswagen you think about
the Volkswagen Beetle but you don't
think about a truck or a pickup truck
like you would if you were thinking
about Dodge Chevy or Ford if you're on
the YouTube version of the podcast let
me know are you what car is your car
what car do you drive what's your
favorite car brand and ultimately when
it comes to positioning if you think
about experts thought leaders
influencers as you rise to a different
level of prominence you want to be known
for a particular position personally
there was a very meaningful moment in my
career when I was actually in Park City
Utah on a snowboard trip with some other
people in the industry I was with Drew
canoli from organifi shellene Johnson
Brett Johnson I was with uh Lewis how
from the school of greatness and I
remember Brett Johnson started to call
me YouTube he'd say hey YouTube we're
going to lunch hey YouTube come in here
and actually as he started to say that I
realized okay this positioning thing
actually has some legs to it and it
started to make me think man you want to
be a meaningful specific in a world of
wandering generalities what's the how
would you like people to think of you
like what would you want to be known for
what is the position that you want to
own and as the author of YouTube secrets
and at think media as we teach about
video overall but obviously lean a lot
into YouTube certainly not in
everybody's mind but being known for
YouTube Sean canel rhymes with YouTube
channel is a powerful position to
hopefully own the question for you is
what position do you want to own and
instead of asking what you are you
actually want to ask what position do
you already own in the the mind of the
prospect or what ultimately is already
in their mind currently what is their
understanding of of certain products or
offerings in the marketplace let me give
you an example when someone doesn't know
you yet and they're trying to make sense
of what you do you could compare what
you do to something they already
understand so I heard somebody in
personal development they started like a
membership platform and they said it's
like Netflix for personal development
that might bring some clarity to people
they're like okay I know what Netflix is
why because Netflix has a position in
our minds we're like oh it's a place of
streaming content of on demand content
and then you think okay personal
development or let's say leadership
resources and if you wanted to launch a
YouTube It's like a Netflix for
leadership content again that would be
positioning so what position do you own
your goal is to find a way into the Mind
by hooking your product service or
concept to what's already there what's
already in their mind you know what what
I'm kind of trying to do is a a
combination of Evan carmichel where he
does compilations with doctors so Evan
carmichel does like Oprah and rules of
success from Tony Robbins or Gary
vaynerchuk what if you did a health
channel that was like Evan carmichel
meets doctors now a lot of people
probably on a macro Across America or
the world may or may not know some of
these examples that we're talking about
but remember these questions are easy to
ask hard to answer and so if you're
trying to make your YouTube channel make
sense if you're trying to cast the
vision of your YouTube channel it is
powerful to think about what is in the
mind of your prospect what is the way
they're thinking if they if I read your
channel cover right now how can you make
a statement on the cover of your YouTube
channel or a tagline in the beginning of
your videos that will make your topic
sticky oh that makes sense oh I want to
subscribe to that oh I would love to
follow your YouTube channel the only way
to get heard is to tell the customer
what they already know the the only way
to get heard is to tell the viewer what
they already know this might sound
challenging again you're like I have new
content a new idea how can you attach
that new content and that new idea to
something that
people understand you know I'm like the
Netflix for personal development I'm
like the Netflix for whatever it is
you're attaching it to something they
understand something they already know
and then introducing your concept and
number one what position do you own if
you're just starting the answer might
not be any which brings us to number two
what position do you want to own this
would be now thinking about okay what do
I want to be known for what position in
the marketplace would I want to be known
for and in a past episode we kind of
talked about this let me use my ex as an
example and I want you to think about
how this could apply to you your channel
your expertise your Niche so the
question I would ask is who owns the
YouTube coaching or education space and
I'm very familiar with a lot of
incredibly bright people I want to be
clear that this is also they may be
competitors but a lot of these
individuals are friends a lot of these
individuals are people that I
collaborate with and I also am a big
believer in the world of abundance I
believe that uh the world is abundant
that there is um a lot of opportunity
for everybody and I know this because a
lot of my peers in the YouTube coaching
space are all doing great but
nevertheless the question is if we
understand that it's all love and at the
same time we're thinking about okay who
owns the YouTube coaching space and as I
look across that landscape this is would
be me asking what position do I want to
own the YouTube coaching space not that
there wouldn't be room for anybody else
but if it makes sense you know that's
what I would want to be know now the
opportunity though is that may be too
broad I'm thinking about a book that I
discovered recently it was called
YouTube for real estate agents and I
thought oh that actually is a great
Insight when it comes to positioning
because while somebody might be broadly
trying to help people when it comes to
the YouTube coaching space there's the
opportunity to Niche down a little bit
and what a great book title YouTube for
real estate agents and that would even
be different than Real Estate Investors
or some of these other disciplines right
so what position do you want to own a
mistake is trying to own a position that
is too broad it can't be established in
the prospect's mind and even if it could
it couldn't be defended so when it talks
about positioning while you also might
be able to like be known for a season or
be known for one viral video or one
campaign the questions the book is
trying to get us to answer is how could
we establish a position that would be
defendable over time chances are
narrowing down makes it a lot better now
while I might want to be influential in
the YouTube coaching space that's a
position I want to own it also could be
a lot broader than that if I was like I
want to be the leading expert on all
social media difficult to own that
position because
there's so much to know about so many
different platforms and that's why for
social media coaches or Educators
somebody specializing in LinkedIn or
somebody specializing on Tik Tok is a
big opportunity and this is the space I
understand the most so again think about
how that applies to you and so then
thinking somebody who specializes on Tik
Tok for Network marketers M now it's
like yeah hey she's the leading expert
on how to use Tik Tok to grow a network
marketing business these become
more ownable or more defendable
positions the tip here is it's better to
narrow the focus of your expertise and
establish a unique position as a
specialist not a jack of all trades
generalist question number three whom
must I outgun great question what
position does no one else have a firm
grip on uh defending a position is easy
establishing it is hard so who must I
outgun ideally you would plant your flag
in a position that nobody else has
claimed yet how is that possible well in
the example they use in the book from
Volkswagen they talked about Volkswagen
competing with other sedans and other
trucks and other SUVs and other Vans and
they couldn't really crack the code and
then they invented the Volkswagen Beetle
it was entirely different than
everything else this is why we often say
different is better than better and so
if possible it'd be great to establish a
position right now for example AI is
brand new it's it's a very new format
maybe it's been around for a long time
but it's new as far as the kind of
consumer public uh using some of these
AI tools and so whenever something new
comes along it's definitely possible to
maybe create a show or video podcast
about something new there could be
something that's like a a new diet keto
was rising in popular popularity
recently obviously ketosis is something
that humans have been going in and out
of of forever uh but certain Trends
happen at certain times the risk being
that maybe you plant your flag as the
number one Clubhouse expert if you
remember that audio app and you make a
course on clubhouse and a book on
clubhouse and then Clubhouse Falls in
popularity and it maybe was the wrong
thing to position yourself in but
nevertheless um you would be positioning
yourself in something new or something
different if you want to position
yourself in something established the
question is whom must you out
gun and this is obviously an incredible
list of questions for business owners of
course for Content creators and a very
good question because we start thinking
about okay how hard is this going to be
what kind of team do I need to build how
much money do I need one of the things
they talk about in the book is AD spend
and I know we we talk a lot about
organic content here on the think media
podcast but they talk about do you have
enough money do you have enough cash to
burn in the establishment of your brand
of brand awareness money could be spent
on ads spend it also could be spent on
traveling events you know sponsoring
events opening up booths depending on
what your business is whom must I outgun
who are maybe some of the big
competitors obviously if we apply it to
some of the traditional things in
business you know Ford is thinking about
okay what's Chevy up to what Dodge up to
what's Tesla up to what's Hyundai up to
whom must I out gun how can we be
different where are they going next
what's happening with electric vehicles
what's happening next and so ultimately
what position does no one else have a
firm grip on as you maybe audit the
evolution of your YouTube channel and
where you want to go next you could be
thinking okay I see a little bit of a
gap in the marketplace over here maybe I
could specialize down here no one really
has a firm grip on this no one's really
committed to this specific area and I do
want to point you to again earlier
episodes where we talked about not just
positioning but the other book marketing
Warfare where we talk about the four
types of warfare we're link to that
episode and whether that's going to be
defense offense flanking or Guerilla
Warfare because picking out maybe how
focused right the narrow focus of your
expertise the unique position as a
specialist is going to be key and then
you define that position but
establishing it is hard you know if all
of this seems daunting and if it's kind
of knocked the wind out of you a little
bit because you just go man man when I
think about my competitors and I look at
the comp comptition it's kind of
discouraging Sean and I want you to know
two things number one you can do this
take a deep breath don't quit just lean
in one step at a time one video at a
time but number two it's going to be
hard if it feels painful welcome to the
club if it feels challenging welcome to
the marketplace of business I know that
in our world right now we want things to
all be like butterflies and soft and
it's all great it's all going to be easy
but literally the other book in this
series is called marketing Warfare we've
been in a series on the podcast talking
all about lessons from military
strategist one of my mentors Patrick ped
David has a t-shirt that says business
is Warfare now that's a little intense
for me because I do think that business
is value and it's customer service and
it's love but it's also hard and so when
you think about who must I outgun I know
that for some of us listening to this
that's kind of challenging cuz we want
it to all be Kum by yaah but there
there's no doubt about it there is
supply and demand there is market
dynamics there is red oceans and blue
oceans there is different challenges
that we face and so these are powerful
questions that should then lead us to
strategic action that helps us take to
territory in our Niche on our YouTube
channel and in our business number four
do you have enough money do you have
enough money it takes money to build a
share of Mind spend enough money to get
above the noise level we had a guest on
the podcast a while AG go ago David
Meltzer and in a different setting he
shared with me this tip that I'll never
forget it's one of my favorite quotes
about business and he said the
secret to business is staying in
business how profound is that do you
just laugh out loud you know what I mean
it actually is an incredibly profound
quote why the funny thing about business
itself assuming you open up an LLC if
that entity is still in business and is
not
bankrupt even if you have debt because
you can always climb out of debt if you
can just survive keep the lights on keep
the door open keep going to your home
office after you make a cup of coffee if
you can stay in business then you can
always you can always come back you
could always climb out of debt maybe you
have a down year maybe you have a down
decade but you could always come back of
course when does it officially end it
ends when the business shuts down when
when you go bankrupt when you you give
up when you stop and so the secret of
business is to stay in business so often
times we think about do you have enough
money it's just do you have enough
staying power again you could fund your
side Hustle YouTube channel from your
current business if you're like I love
my rhythm my 9 to5 is not too bad I've
got a nice salary and I kind of like my
side hustle and I'm happy to just chip
away at my YouTube channel I'll do it
for two years 5 years 10 years and maybe
10 years from now I know this nobody
likes to think that long but maybe 10
years from now just because of the
consistency and the learning and you've
been listening to the thick media
podcast we've been hanging out and then
there's a Tipping Point where it's like
oh cool I'm still in it I've been
learning I've been uploading but now's
my time to go all in do you have enough
money to get there cool thing about
YouTube channels is they're very low
overhead ultimately they can be very low
liability but then on the other side
talking about much more of an
offensive scale your business scale your
YouTube channel mentality it takes money
to build share of mind it takes money to
hire people it takes money to invest in
software or AI tools and tools to
publish more content you know think
media is on offense last time I checked
we're publishing around 350 pieces of
content a week and we are very much here
on the podcast to encourage you as a
brand new YouTube channel as a solo
Creator getting things started but also
this game of media this landscape of
publishing content across channels not
just YouTube but all the social media
channels we don't just publish that many
pieces of content cuz it sounded like a
good idea and it's fun it is kind of fun
but it's also uh Dressed in overalls and
it looks like work like it's challenging
to try to think about the systems and
the team and the organization and the
tracking of it all and tracking the
return on investment the ROI tracking
return on investment roaz return on ads
spend tracking what you're putting out
there the bottom line is that whether
it's team whether it's investing in
technology whether it's investing in
travel whether it's investing in ad
spend it takes money to build share of
mind so depending on the hill you're
trying to tackle depending on the giant
you're trying to slay if you've narrowed
your expertise well then that might cost
a little bit less money if you're trying
to shoot for the stars and build a media
company do you have enough money and
their encouragement to spend enough
money to get above the noise level I
think should be something we're cautious
with but thoughtful of Dave Ramsey would
be kind of you know shaking in his boots
right now because of course he would
encourage you not to go into debt he
would encourage you to cut up your
credit cards but if you look at what
entrepreneurs do and you look at startup
companies they take on a lot of times
Venture Capital they take on investors
sometimes they raise a million five
10100 million and then they hire teams
and they scale and they hope they make
it and sometimes they reach insolvency
and it all crashes and burns now for us
as startup creators I'm not suggesting
that you incur a bunch of debt and go
crazy but I think there's a lot of
lessons that we can learn from
traditional startups and I think that
when you apply that to if you will the
smaller Arena of like a homebased
YouTube business are you spending enough
money to get above the noise level could
you spend more money to get above the
Way's level that's whether setting money
aside so you can go all in on YouTube
investing in technology investing in
coaching investing in your learning
investing in paid ads Sean should I
spend paid ads on my organic content
just to answer that question no you
shouldn't but if you have a product or a
Service hiring an agency hiring somebody
learning how to run meta ads or whatever
it is like just are you spending enough
money to get above the noise level and
how could you invest more in your
business if we're applying positioning
the battle for your mind again certain
enemies are going to take a certain
level of energy resources troops to win
the Victory and if you don't deploy
enough of all of the above then you may
not break through these questions are
easy to ask but hard to answer and this
brings us to number five can you stick
it out we've already been touching on
this but can you stick it out I loved
this question man this chapter of the
book and by the way um I had our entire
uh Team directors and the directors of
think media read this we haven't quite
done it yet but we're going to spend
like an entire day discussing
positioning so if you're a serious
YouTube strategist we'll link that up in
the show notes um definitely check out
the book positioning and uh any other
resources that we'll put in there but
can you stick it out determine your
basic position and then stick to it
listen to this most successful companies
rarely change a winning
formula H one of the things I've learned
about YouTube content creators and I am
one is inherent in the name is Creator
and behind that is the word creative and
the problem with creatives and
entrepreneurs is we have
365 ideas every single day we want to
start new channels we want to start new
podcasts we want to write new books
we've got 42 different course ideas
you've got a bunch of different things
you want to start you want to interview
a bunch of different people half of
which have nothing to do with your
actual Channel you want to collaborate
with a bunch of people most of which
probably wouldn't even be that good of
collaborations but you just have all
these ideas and all these things going
through your head most successful
companies find a winning formula and
then they stick with that winning
formula if I go all the way back up to
like who owns the YouTube coaching space
and I'm honest with you there's not like
a day goes by when I start thinking you
know what I've been talking about this
YouTube thing a lot you know I I think
there's some other things I'd want to
talk about and I'm super blessed and I'm
so thankful for you because I know we
kind of like I'm finding an outlet here
on the think media podcast to talk about
strategy with you to talk about
leadership to talk about business
because that's the stuff I really geek
out on to talk about faith to talk about
principles from the Bible even there's a
lot of different stuff we cover on the
podcast and I'm weaving it into YouTube
but the truth is for us that think media
our best
strategy is to double down and triple
down on what we're already doing and I
have to be very disciplined as the CEO
to be thinking about not messing up our
winning formula we've actually had
consistent successive wins we definitely
have our challenges we definitely have
some challenges that can hit us certain
months but I even was talking about
recently on a podcast how we've done
growth video live five times and number
six is coming soon by the way if you're
not on the waiting list or you haven't
got early bird tickets grow withv
live.com it's coming back may of 2026 or
at least spring of 2024 is the more
accurate year 2026 is well but that's a
little further out in the future so
ultimately I was thinking about our
first event we lost $220,000 it was
super hard we didn't know what we were
doing but since then we have not lost
money and most successful companies
rarely change a winning formula and one
of the things we're trying to do is like
learn from the last one and in a way do
it again now that's not to say that it's
going to be like boring and the same
stuff what I mean is the formula like
what was the schedule what how should it
be structured how could we do ticketing
how could we do pricing I want to
caution you from switching things up too
much if you're in the season of trying
to figure out your winning formula you
might want to be doing more
experimentation but seasoned business
owner seasoned YouTuber seasoned
entrepreneur listen most successful
companies rarely change a winning
formula a company should almost never
change its basic position positioning
strategy only its tactics the short-term
Maneuvers that support the long-term
strategy you know recently we are
talking about with our content we it's
been a while since we've really gone
deep on Tech and we're going to be
getting back into Tech especially on the
think media channel and what's
interesting about that is I it is my
conviction as the founder of think media
and as a studier of the
marketplace that our original position
of being one of if not hopefully yeah
one of the influential channels about
like best camera for YouTube Not Just
best camera in general not the best
camera for film making but best camera
for YouTube that was one of the original
videos that six seven eight years ago
actually helped me even get our company
to where it is today the question is as
relevant as it ever has been cameras
continue to change there's different
models there's different comparisons and
a company should almost never change its
basic positioning strategy that's also
why people subscribed in the first place
so if you start shifting away people
start going well the reason I came to
you was for this if I wanted something
different I would switch it up now you
can change your tactics and you should
what are tactics they're the short-term
Maneuvers that support the long-term
strategy But ultimately your long-term
strategy once you've got it dialed in
your long-term strategy when it comes to
your positioning most successful comp
companies lock that down and then of
course what what does that mean not use
YouTube shorts no of course you should
use YouTube shorts and vertical video
across platforms and all the little
bells and whistles but those are tactics
what is your strategy and listen to this
positioning is cumulative that's also
why me as hopefully a a growing leader
in maturity and growing in wisdom
realizing that positioning is cumulative
it just means that all of the success of
yesterday that you can compound will
continue to grow if you stay focused and
stick it out can you stick it out might
mean do you have the money to stick it
out do you have the time what is your
life circumstances what is the team
that's around you the people that are
around you can you stick it out is also
probably a mental question though like
do you even want to stick it out do you
actually see yourself committed to this
topic over the long term do you see
yourself actually finding enough
fascination with it and what I'm
grateful for is even though there's a
lot of these other things that I'm
thinking about I picked a horse I bet on
this YouTube horse I bet on this online
video horse and it's something that I A
lot of times have to rekindle my fire
for but I'm glad that I did it because
it is something that when I get my mind
right and my heart right I'm like yeah I
I love this stuff like let's go I love
this online marketing stuff this video
stuff this YouTube stuff let let me go
deeper on it positioning is cumulative
can I stick with YouTube for 16 years
well I have so far and and can I do do
it for the next 16 well we'll see but
let's keep building this momentum so
Take the Long View and find new ways to
dramatize it so good right so this is
all from the book can I stick it out
find new ways to take an old thing and
package it in a fresh way find new ways
to share the proven hard one strategies
a lot of times we do that on the think
media podcast I hear the critics say
Sean you're saying the same things a lot
yeah I mean if it's like a proven
principle that is proven to bring
success on YouTube
you probably need to hear the same
things repeated a lot but hopefully in
fresh ways so how can you dramatize it
how can you not only continue to sell
your listeners and your viewers and your
community on the opportunity packaging
it helping them see the potential see
the same things in new ways think about
Crest or Colgate toothpaste have you
purchased any recently at the department
store or the grocery store what does it
say on the package it says new and
improved two obser obervations number
one it is impossible for something to be
new and improved if it's new then it
can't be improved because it would
actually have to be old and improved
observation number two it's not freaking
new what do you mean new there's no
Innovations in toothpaste forgive me if
you're a toothpaste manufacturer like
why do they say new because they're
taking something like toothpaste and
there's a fresh packaging to it there's
maybe a new aspect to it maybe they
added charcoal cuz charcoal is the trend
in toothpaste right and so you're
finding new ways to dramatize it can you
stick with your Niche can you stick with
your YouTube channel can you stick with
your business idea what is the Long View
of all of the above what is the position
that you're trying to continue to double
down on invest money in
compound build momentum continue to
stack because positioning is cumulative
and if you're a little tired and you're
a little weary which I can relate to can
you schedule some time to dramatize it
for yourself to sew yourself on it again
tired eyes rarely see a bright future
maybe you need a nap maybe you need a
break but maybe you need to dust off a
book or maybe you need to go to an event
or travel a little bit to reinvigorate
your passion and your love for the very
thing that you've been doing for a while
before we get to number six to go a
little bit deeper on this I have a lot
of empathy because it's so funny
recently uh somebody that's very
respected and influential that's worked
at YouTube and has built a lot of
influence I I messaged him I was
surprised he knew who I was and he goes
oh Sean you're an OG in the YouTube
space and his words carried a lot of
weight because as is he and he had
worked at YouTube for years and it was
kind of encouraging but it also was sort
of like a moment when I was like shoot
am I that old you know what I mean I'm
like man I've been here I've been doing
this thing for a while and one of the
things I've noticed about content
creators is there something about year
five six year 10 that it's hard to like
stay passionate question is can you
stick it out I believe you can of course
if you want to Pivot you want to launch
something new it's totally fine to
transition but perhaps you just need
some time to dramatize it again to
repackage it for yourself to to figure
out the 4.0 version of your personal
brand of your identity to to figure out
what is this next season going to look
like and
coming with question number five is a
warning line extension weakens your
basic position this is a conversation
for an entire episode but just briefly
touching on this what is line extension
line extension is when a company like
NyQuil what do you think about when you
think about NyQuil you know exactly what
it is it's something that you have the
flu and you want to fall asleep you're
going to take NyQuil it's when somebody
like NyQuil decides to extend extend
their line and create something and I'll
make this up but if you were to have
like NyQuil Q-tips you know like they're
like well we're soled in the pharmacy
area and we people need Q-tips to clean
their ears out as well I don't even
actually think that Q-tips that's
speaking of positioning I think they're
called like cotton swabs like on the end
of a stick and Q-Tip is a brand name
that actually has positioning in my mind
so ultimately the punchline is if if
you've got a product like NyQuil if you
have a product even like Tylenol and
they've certainly launched 462 different
versions of it line extension they
proved in the book often times weakens
your basic position it dilutes your
basic position and what these companies
will do like a Proctor and Gamble or
these different companies is they
actually will launch new brands it's not
that you shouldn't launch new things
it's that they will launch entire new
brand names so that NyQuil can mean
NyQuil Tylenol can mean Tylenol and
Airborne can mean Airborne so airborn
it's like okay the thing you take when
you're going to fly so you don't get
sick but if you go like you know
Airborne to help you sleep no that's n
quil's thing right so ultimately line
extension how does this apply to us as
content creators oh man it's the biggest
temptation of all you know what is think
media known for I would ask what is the
think media podcast known for line
extension could be trying to cover too
many other social media platforms I hope
you subscribe to this uh this podcast
mainly for YouTube about once a year we
go to social media marketing world and
we drop some content around the other
platforms and we have a Tik Tok episode
and a Facebook episode we touch on those
because we certainly are hopefully known
for online video but line extension
weakens your basic position if you
remember my snowboarding trip Brett
Johnson was like Hey YouTube come in
here and if I started to try to be known
for YouTube and 32 other things what
gets weakened the basic position what do
you want to be known for and are you
doing too many things now if you want to
start something else eventually that
could mean starting another brand for us
that's maybe starting another podcast
and with the right team and systems the
right things around fine so that that
brand name that thing can be known for
what it's known for it can have its own
positioning and if I know who I must
outgun and I've got enough money and
I've got enough resources and I can
stick it out and I know I can stick it
out here or whatever the systems are
it's not that you shouldn't launch a new
thing but line extension ultimately
weakens your basic position what do you
ultimately want to be known for the
final example if if you're still needing
a little Clarity there would be imagine
if Toyota started making luxury cars and
just called them Toyota plus it wouldn't
even compare to the success of Lexus but
Toyota and Lexus are the same company so
instead of Toyota just calling their
name Toyota luxury Toyota is known for
being pretty decent cars highly rated
good consumer ratings affordable but not
luxury you want Al Lexus some people may
not even know that Toyota and Lexus are
owned by the same people but what does
Lexus insinuate it's going to be a
little bit more expensive it's going to
be a little bit higher end do not line
extend Toyota launch an entirely second
car company
an entire brand called Lexus can you
stick it out with your current brand
message Focus Niche avoid line extension
because it'll weaken your basic position
and finally number six do you match your
position this chapter was good for me
man it had me ask some questions that
are easy to ask but are hard to answer
do you match your position are you
currently in alignment with what you
want to be known for for is the look
colors brand of your position congruent
with the message you're putting out
there my favorite example of this which
is kind of an anti- example a negative
example is there's a lot of people that
talk about personal finance wealth and
money on YouTube or on the Internet
which I'm all for and I think that one
of the best subjects to get educated in
is to get a financial education but I
always find it humorous when somebody is
trying to say like projecting the image
of financial stability of wealth a
financial wisdom let's say on YouTube
and I see this a lot and they're filming
in an echoey kitchen with clutter behind
them on a folded card table table with
not great audio it looks like they
didn't take a shower that day they
didn't put together their appearance
their set their brand their lighting
their video or their audio now your
argument might be well that person could
be the wisest person of all perhaps but
we judge books by their cover do you
match your position what you're claiming
to be known for claiming expertise in do
you've got the receipts to back it up
are you credentialed and then visually
do your match your position do your ads
if you're publishing ads actually speak
the message you want them to speak do
your clothes actually convey the message
you want to convey do you match your
position and what they said was that
creativity by itself is worthless only
when it's subordinated to the
positioning objective can it make a
contribution this will offend a lot of
artists but it's a very good business
lesson that we need just being creative
for Creative sake isn't necessarily
helpful again if we thought okay we
could make the video kind of cool I
could wear this and we could do this but
what is the tone of the video the look
of the video the way you're
communicating the message that's coming
across does it back up the actual
message that that you are trying to say
or is there cognitive dissidence you
know we've all seen content where
someone's like saying one thing but all
we can pay attention to is what's being
communicated and what they're not saying
body language dress attire location and
so do you match your position and
ultimately you could think about this
where sometimes somebody will be like
I'm an expert at launching books or
something like that like I I'm an expert
in in in writing books launching books
so I'll go look at their book and I and
just always wonder why do they have zero
or one Amazon review I mean that's one
of the only things I can assess but I go
to Amazon of this very claiming a they
have the ability to be a successful
author right or help people launch Books
and yet their book only has one review
I'm not trying to step on your toes I'm
just trying to encourage you that that
just speaks something they're
positionings as one thing but the case
studies or the visuals or the results or
the Public Image or the perception which
may or may not be reality regardless
their perception is not matching up and
just trying to be creative in your
marketing or just trying to be creative
is not helpful if it's not subordinated
to the positioning objective and
actually making a contribution to that
goal creativity is amazing but the
bigger question is what is the
positioning objective you may feel like
doing something certainly one other
example I could think about is in this
world of uh churches and Ministry one of
the things that I find interesting and
this is a funny kind of rabbit hole to
go down but it's a powerful illustration
is what message is a pastor trying to
convey from the platform and there's
this controversial account called
preachers and sneakers for example it's
kind of a this is a niche thing if
you're in like the Christian world you
know about this but one of the things
that this account would cover is that in
the world of Christianity and in the
world of sharing the Bible and sharing
the gospel
that ultimately this account started to
take these screenshots and show pictures
of different pastors that were wearing
$800 sneakers or 8,000 sneakers or all
this different kind of clothes and stuff
now if you asked my opinion on the
matter I kind of don't care however as
an observer and one that thinks about
marketing and positioning and messaging
I actually do think it's pretty
important and I think it could be unwise
if what you do on stage ultimately hurt
hurts the message you're trying to get
across should pastors be able to wear
whatever they want I think so do we know
that they bought whatever from like
tithe dollars from the church maybe it
was a gift who cares the bottom line
though is is it effective because
creativity itself is worthless you
ultimately want to support it to the
positioning you want it subordinated to
the positioning objective and if we're
going to accurately represent the
message of Jesus the message of Christ I
want to do my best job of course dress
cool or dress whatever but if there's
something that's going to get in the way
of your objective then why do it and
also why do it on stage or on camera or
on YouTube when you could do it
elsewhere and you might say well Sean
that's my right or like I you're
absolutely right but it just might not
be wise because ultimately I want to
express myself and my creativity cool
and perhaps you understand your mission
and what you're trying to do and what
you're trying to get across but if
ultimately it's misconstrued and
misinterpreted not saying that's right
or wrong I just think a lot of people
lack wisdom because what's the
positioning objective what does winning
actually look like and is anything
you're doing with your brand ultimately
hurting the positioning objective these
were six questions that will lead to
your success on YouTube they're easy to
ask but they could be hard to answer and
I believe if you take some time to think
deeply about these and come up with some
great personal answers or forget the
pressure of saying great answers if you
just take time to like think about these
apply these to your Channel apply these
to your long-term thinking your strategy
your branding I really believe that more
views and more success is waiting for
you on the other side I want to remind
you that if you want to go a little bit
deeper we have a free class at think
masterclass.com that is actually going
to get a lot more tactical than this
we've been in these conversations that
are kind of at a high level strategic
level and honestly a critical level but
ultimately we also got to roll up our
sleeves and actually apply some tactics
that will get us views and if you want
to watch an on demand class for for an
hour I'll actually share with you the
best way we the best thing we're doing
right now at think media that's
generating over 350,000 views every
single day you can check out that free
class at
think.com or there's also a link in the
show notes to that free on demand class
now if you also check out the show notes
I want to encourage you to take some
time to check out other videos in this
series we've been doing this for a while
now on the think media podcast we're
talking about positioning Art of War by
Suns Su on War by Carl Von clout Switz
we're looking at military generals and I
hope you've been getting a lot of value
from some of the Strategic thinking our
company's called think media because we
ultimately want to help you think deeper
we want to help you think different we
want to help you think bigger and also
think more strategically and so that
playlist in that series I think will be
a great assistant in for your journey
and your success on YouTube and if
you've been getting out of this episode
if you're on the YouTube version that's
the only place you are really able to
comment I would love to hear any of your
insights from these six questions what
stood out to you how did this challenge
you did it maybe reveal something that
now that you know that or you see that
it's going to help you make better
decisions going forward and wherever you
watch or listen to the podcast if you
like rate or review it does really help
us to get the word out if you also maybe
know somebody I would love it if you
shared this episode you know one of the
way ways the audio podcast spreads is
word of mouth and so maybe DM somebody
this episode or let maybe one person in
your world I think these six questions
will help maybe they're not a YouTube
Creator you probably see by now that if
they're a creative entrepreneur they
lead a nonprofit they lead a church
these six questions can be just really
helpful for getting clear and ultimately
getting better results in all of our
endeavors so I want to appreciate you
thanks for listening to the end for the
two people that are still here and I
can't wait to connect with you in a
future episode of the think media
podcast